el batallón azul ha sido oficialmente
declarado formación terrorista en rusia
ahora todas sus actividades quedan
oficialmente
prescritas en la federación rusa aunque
en realidad el batallón azov nunca ha
operado el suelo ruso para lo que es
importante esta sentencia del tribunal
supremo ruso es para poder endurecer las
penas y los castigos contra los miembros
del batallón azor muchos de ellos están
ahora mismo presos del ejército ruso
después de la brutal ofensiva rusa en la
ciudad ucraniana de mariupol rusia acusa
a los integrantes del batallón azor de
usar la violencia contra los opositores
contra los disidentes y de presionar
también a la población rusoparlante de
donbass en ucrania también les acusan de
llevar a cabo ejecuciones y secuestros
aunque según a muchas organizaciones
internacionales y también medios
internacionales es precisamente rusia la
que está llevando a cabo estas acciones
ahora mismo en su país vecino en ucrania